so
Stanley you did something very fun cuz
like everyone on my crew is a High
School Musical fan and
so it's like it's like American Idol
you're never going to get away you know
what I'm saying it's kind of cool though
that people know you and and love you
from that but I heard that you did a
tribute to Zach impromptu on set yeah I
mean I think uh anyone from my
generation I I I think it would be a
disservice to anyone from my generation
I if I didn't do something and and uh
and uh yeah I mean we had like a Live
party scene we did we did and uh I I was
playing music and I the night before I
was fretting about the scene and the
night before I I learned the chords to
to to Breaking Free and and I uh gave a
little rendition uh in in front of in
front of Zach and it was and it was
right before my coverage was welled oh
it's right before you have to like be
serious or something yeah yeah it was
pretty funny he did it kind of sneaky as
well he was like I'm sorry like
did you enjoy the tri do you enjoy when
people still come up to I still look
it's been over 20 years but I still love
when people like I voted for you because
I'm like thank you um but like do you I
well thank you it worked um but do you
still love it like cuz it's one of those
things that I think when people first
get to know you there's something
special about it oh definitely I mean I
cuz you were a baby yeah uh I mean it
means the world it's so fun I the other
day in Hollywood uh he got his Stu
the oh
congratulations that's awesome man um
but there were there were so many wild
catchers he's out and the fans are are
still out there in force it's fun though
cuz you know they they used to be uh you
know really young and now now it's
there's like there's like 40-year-old
there yeah so it's awesome man like I
love it I love I love it it promotes it
promotes like a pretty cool Nostalgia
for people like you know from from back
in the day that's pretty cool yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home